ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show we are in the midst of
Twitter gate this is a big deal big news
big story epic huge this is big it's our
boy Hunter Biden's laptop uh if you
remember that Elon Musk uh who now owns
Twitter
um and he what he has done is he is uh
given internal documents to Matt taibi
who's a journalist about the supposed
and it seems pretty I won't even say the
word supposed it seems pretty uh
established that the suppression of
Hunter Biden's laptop
story now you remember Hunter Biden is
the president's son he's a crackhead he
likes [ __ ] he has all of that on a lap
I don't know why he has every photo of
everyone he's [ __ ] in every crack pipe
he's ever put into his mouth in a
[ __ ] Google drive but he does he has
everything that he's ever done it makes
no sense to me I'm a guy that used to do
drugs not as many as Hunter button and I
didn't have that much fun doing it but
it never occurred to me in the midst of
my drug use like straw in nose Over CD
case it was the Gin Blossoms doing a
line I never said to myself why don't I
have a [ __ ] photograph of this why
don't I have you know why he's in this
documented but every single thing Hunter
Biden has ever done is documented and
it's on a [ __ ] laptop and the laptop
went to a
I guess a uh laptop repair shop
and he just left it this is apparently
what happened Hunter Biden on crack with
hookers photos on the laptop also as he
has this weird job at burisma which is
some Energy company in our favorite
country the Ukraine
Hunter Biden's dad got him the job or
maybe or the idea that they would have
some closeness with the dad inspired
them I don't know that Hunter Biden was
really uh you know uh uh
enthused about natural gas or that he
had a passion for energy this is some
type of uh sweetheart gig that he had
all of this
uh starts looking and feeling like a
scandal
um whether it is or not but it probably
is
um this is a story about a father and a
son
and uh I mean Joe Biden and I've said
this before he said the most tragic life
of anyone I've ever I mean he's like I
mean like Joe Biden one son died of a
brain tumor the other son is a crackhead
started dating the one son who's died's
wife started [ __ ] his wife okay
um I believe Joe Biden's first family if
you can look this up I think they're old
like dead I think Biden's first wife
died like Joe Biden's first
the family was like some type of tragic
situation too like they're all
yeah yeah she died his first wife died
yeah she died God
so this was a she died in a car crash
with her one-year-old daughter Naomi
her two sons bow and Hunter were both
critically injured but survived the
wreck so this family has like a gypsy
curse put on them I've always said that
maybe Biden had sold his soul to the
devil for power and the devil said well
I'll make you president but you're gonna
I'm gonna take a lot in on in the way on
the way it's like nothing I've ever seen
it makes you feel bad for him right
right I mean even though he's you know
whatever he put a bunch of black people
in jail and he's probably done some
horrible things himself it's it's sad
when you look at his entire life is
tragic right so now he's got this son
Hunter and this laptop and the story
comes out in the New York Post there's
like all kinds of [ __ ] on this laptop
it's not good
and now Twitter
goes on the laptop and the Twitter
safety group whoever the people are that
handle uh the Twitter misinformation
because you got to remember it was all
Russia and Russia is coming and they're
gonna make you believe yeah you know and
it was the whole thing about how
everybody's rushing your aunt is Russian
who likes Trump she's everybody who was
Russian or Chinese and everyone's a bot
or a troll and nobody was real who's
real who's real is Uncle Ralph Real no
he's Russian the Russians put him up to
it everything uh after Trump was elected
was about how Russia had apparently
taken over all of Facebook and started
posting as your aunts and uncles nobody
really voted for trump it was now listen
was Russia [ __ ] with our elections
sure have we [ __ ] with all of theirs
yes was it an overreaction by the
intelligence community in America
seemingly a bit because they then spent
two years going Trump's a Russian asset
and they couldn't prove any of it but
they had to sit down with Twitter all
the time and they had to go there's
disinformation coming you better get
ready are you ready for the
disinformation and you know the people
at Twitter they want to be good I met
some of these people not they're working
Twitter but I know who they are they go
to Stanford and they're you know they're
like we are Elite and we are the
utopians and we are ushering in A Brave
New World where everyone's gonna love
each other and be nice to each other and
say these words are not those words and
they'll get the right information at the
right time so they can make the right
decision then by the right decision I
mean the decision that we made three
months ago that they're going to now
adopt this is the way they believe this
is what they think and they eat
dumplings and vegan food and and you
know not because they're all Asian but
there is a there is a contingent and
there's nothing wrong with that but this
is you know I like the Asian culture
it's a very clean culture and there's a
lot we can learn from them but the thing
of what I'm saying here I'm not I'm not
going Kanye here relax what I'm saying
is that you you have it's a different
culture Tech is different Finance is
more aggressive and aggro Tech is a
little bit more you know it's a cold and
cool man manipulative kind of sociopath
culture they really believe they're
doing the right thing they really
believe it they really believe that you
just got to get on board the whole thing
is about getting you on board with all
of the solutions that are going to fix
your life and this little thing you have
in your head called a brain is no good
and they have to figure out how to
basically have you relate it's like a
plane you know when they started taking
the pilots out of the uh aircraft the
plane started crashing less because the
planes now do most of the work this is
the way that tech people kind of think
about the world if they can get you out
of the decision-making process of
whatever it happens to be voting for who
you want taking a vaccine whatever it is
they don't want you in the process they
want to remove you from the process as
much as possible uh because you don't
have the information they have the
information they're the Guardians of the
information so every week and this is
again I I listen to y'all Roth uh on on
Kara Swisher's podcast I've listened to
vijigati before she's been on Rogan and
stuff like that I don't think these are
evil people by Nature I think they are
kind of drunk on their own power a
little bit and I think they have like a
it's like a mom complex have you ever
met him like a real mom
who's like you know I used to have an
auntie Michelle who was like a mom she
was like what's going on like she has
that energy you know what I mean like
like a like a mom who's like with a
shirt that says it's wine o'clock and
you know what I mean and she's like a
martyr and she's like if you knew half
of what I had to deal with you know how
many Nazis I deal with on a daily basis
and it's a mom energy it's like a it's
like a drunk wine mom who's had enough
of her [ __ ] kids and she comes in the
house and she's like [ __ ] Christ
y'all eat when I say you eat
and you'll watch the things I say you
can watch cause I'm a mom and you can
understand it because that's a mother
but these people a little drunk on their
power they have a little bit of a mom
energy they're like there's a lot of
kids and teenagers and trolls and Nazis
and Russians and Chinese and everybody's
yelling at each other on these sides
nobody really wants to admit that these
sites are just kind of bad right I mean
that would be the real just but we can't
admit that there goes all the money
because we can't admit that that these
these things are easily gamed
um they make us less human the eventual
thing is that they destroy our Humanity
entirely but
between now and then there's a lot of
rev there's a lot of AD Revenue so
people have to go it's almost like it
you know it's almost like going to a
crackhead and going can't you just smoke
a little bit I mean you're embarrassing
yourself you're sitting on the street
can you smoke a little bit at the end of
the day after work and it's like no
they're on crack
so what happens with these sizes it is
kind of funny to watch people debate how
to make them really really great when a
lot of the problems seem like they were
present at the design of these things
and it feels like these things are kind
of working exactly how they're supposed
to work
so Elon Musk so every week or whatever
during the election time the FBI would
sit down with Twitter and go get ready
for it it's coming all of the
disinformation is coming it's a hack
it's a hack and leak they're gonna do a
hacking leak like a Wikileaks they're
gonna hack our government find out that
we've been [ __ ] God Only Knows
shooting civilians in the face in Iraq
or you know that was the Wikileaks thing
but they're gonna then they're gonna
distribute hacked information on your
site and you're gonna be in trouble so
you gotta stop that from happening
because foreign countries want to
embarrass us and expose us you know
that's what they did they sat down every
week with these people and they're like
this is a hack and Lee campaign they're
coming they're going to show you all the
[ __ ] we've been doing and you know it's
almost like somebody in the room will be
like so what are we doing
what are you guys doing like
you know have you ever have you ever
like seen someone go to grab their phone
like you know their phones like this
like where's my phone
and you're like what is on their phone
so there is there is something like that
so now Hunter Biden has a laptop so the
people at Twitter
go on the laptop this is what happens
they go on the laptop they see that all
the child porn is is Tastefully done
they make a decision
they say all of this uh CP on this
laptop is actually very Tastefully done
SCP goes
they bring it in to the visual
anti-gotty and the other guy and they
sit down and they watch the hours and
hours of Hunter Biden chasing [ __ ]
around with a crack pipe and then they
go no I'm kidding I'm that's a joke
maybe I don't know but they basically
decide that the New York Post story
comes out where it's like hundred Biden
they go there's a laptop out there and I
think there's pictures of his hot the
Biden team has said listen we just
didn't want to show pictures of my son's
hog
this is
this is America it's 2022. these are the
issues of the day the Biden team has
come out and they have said the reason
we pushed back and pressure Twitter is
because it's like one of my sons is dead
can you at least have the decency to not
show my other son's hog maybe it's a
nice hot I bet Hunter's got a [ __ ] this
is my bet I bet Hunter has a dick this
is what I think anyone who anyone who
[ __ ] their dead brother's wife you've
got to have a dick right you're gonna
have a dick like she's not doing that
for nothing Hunter's probably got a [ __ ]
it's it's it might have issues it might
I think it might be gnarled where it's
like some dicks are veiny where they
look like there's they were in an
electrical fire there's acquires It
Maybe not maybe it's not pretty but it's
I think it's substantial it's a dick if
I had to guess it's a dick right
so Joe Biden is probably like
listen I don't know what else is going
on I'm sure there's barisma in the
Ukraine and the energy listen I'm sure
that that all plays into it but what
Biden has said this is what he's come
out and said he's gonna listen
they want to show my son's hog
on the internet
they probably had to explain the body
and what was even happening they're
probably like Hunter's got photos out
there
and Biden came up in the era of TV where
they'd blur it out they wouldn't show it
there were three networks even with
cable you could make a phone call you
could put some pressure on somebody but
now it's a it's a circus a mad house you
have to sit him down and he's like hey
what's what's going on you go listen
Hunter's got ah Hunty has been a lot of
problems a lot of problems I know but
they've got his hog uh Hunter hunty's
got a hug yeah yeah they got it they got
photos of it and you're gonna put it all
over the Internet and I think they went
to Twitter and they're like by the way
can you stop with his hog also there's a
lot of other corruption in there we
don't need out anyway but can we please
not have his hog out there
so what you have is Twitter's former
head of trusted safety whole Roth shed
more insight about the decision in an
interview this week noting that the
story set off quote alarm Bell signaling
it might be a hack and League campaign
what did I just say by a Russian group
known as fancy bear
ultimately for me it didn't reach a
place where I was comfortable removing
this content from Twitter somehow it did
get removed Dorsey admitted fault at the
time in a roundabout way straight
blocking of URLs was wrong but we
updated our policy and enforcement to
fix our goal is to attempt to add
contact so here's the reality and they
did not want Trump to win this is quite
clear now you might say
well that's good you hate Trump that's
fine
um you know at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter you know what your
feelings were about uh president Trump
uh president Trump will die eventually I
know that people don't think that's
possible but he will he's old he's gonna
he's gonna he won't live forever so when
we debate things that involve Trump the
problem becomes he's such a big figure
that nobody can have any conversation
about something he's involved in on
principle
everything has to be about him
particularly and on principle we would
all probably agree that it's not a great
idea that you have sites like Twitter
with the ability to disseminate
information in a way that could slant an
election towards one candidate if they
uh see fit that's we would all probably
say that's not great
um that being said it does get messy
because there is information out there
that could be gamed for sure and it
could be fake and I mean wait till the
Deep fakes
start rolling out like if they had deep
fakes of Hunter Biden
you know you know you'd probably have to
figure out like how do we how do we deal
with that you know do we do we just put
it out it could be a deep fake of him
like just [ __ ] a hooker and yelling
and screaming and you know
Hunter Biden is you know they had a
Thanksgiving in Nantucket recently the
Biden family and they were trying to
decide if he was going to run again you
know they had to explain to him number
one you are President they had to sit
him down and go you're the president and
he'd go what you're the president and do
you want to be the president again and
that was very difficult but hunter was
at the dinner so Hunter
and you know this is you saw Biden in
Nantucket
um going up to like Windows uh and like
going into these little cute Christmasy
stores in Nantucket and everybody's
getting excited you know and they're
taking photos of him and he seems happy
he seems happy because he doesn't he's
not the president at that moment he's
just an old man uh walking around a Town
Square uh but hunter was not and I
noticed this I'm like you know Hunter's
there I read that he was there he was
not on the like the town walks with the
family
and you wonder if Hunter asked like if
they're like we're gonna we're gonna
take a walk in there we're gonna go see
the trees you wonder if Hunter's like
hey can I be involved with that
or when they leave does Hunter just
light up in the backyard like a 14 year
old
like does Hunter use that time does
Hunter watch the Secret Service and as
soon as they're out of you as soon as
they're gone does he just walk in the
back and go I'm gonna hit the beach
and just get loaded
and this is a you know this is a real
issue and uh the thing with Trump is
it's trouble live at everything and
anything Trump has no relationship to
the truth I mean some of what Trump has
said has been correct but it's been
correct in a way by accident because
Trump doesn't care if it's correct or
not if it helps Trump trump you know has
blatantly used a q Anon thing to boost
him knowing that it's fake and knowing
that it was designed by people close to
him
um so Trump's word here isn't always you
know obviously it's it's it's not gospel
right so you just got to look at these
things on their face and go what what
are they preventing you from knowing
would you have not voted for Biden if
you knew certain [ __ ] and maybe that's
the case like if you if you saw Hunter's
hog
uh would you have said no
I don't know
but it became to a point where I
remember that story broke and it was
very salacious and then it went away
immediately like overnight it was like
boom we're done
we're done with Hunter Biden and his
crack
the Biden family's tradition of eating
lunch shopping and watching a Christmas
tree lighting in downtown Nantucket
Friday became mostly about keeping the
president's two-year-old grandson from
having a meltdown
what there was President Joe Biden's
daughter Ashley dancing and clapping
with nephew Beau to Jingle Bell Rock to
keep him entertained as they waited for
the crowd
that had gathered for the 48th annual
tree lighting ceremony on Main Street
there was Beau approached on the
shoulders of his dad Hunter Biden oh
wait a minute so Hunters out at the tree
lighting go back there he is he's a
Detroit here I thought he was gone I
thought they locked him in Malibu I and
he's next to a priest
do you think that's the rules that
Hunter can only leave if he's
accompanied by a priest
this is not a bad idea
right next to our president you have his
son Hunter and then a hobbit priest
this Hobbit priest must follow under but
I thought for sure
and I'm I egg on my face here I can't
believe I'm wrong for sure I thought
that Hunter was being kept because
listen I was a junkie when I was a
little kid like when I was in my teens
and you know my parents were like just
fall back like we don't we don't have to
bring you everywhere you're a problem
you're a liar you're a thief and you're
a degenerate so until you clean that up
we're not going to the Christmas tree
lighting with you now maybe Hunter is
cleaning up can you zoom in on Hunter's
face as close as you can get because I'm
I'm curious no
[Laughter]
is that the face of someone who's turned
over a new Leaf
Biden by the way does this not look like
a weird thing where they've inserted
Biden into do they even look like
they're together
like it feels Photoshop the whole thing
by the way look at this photo and I'm
not trying to be a conspiracy theorist
but that's who I am and how I've made my
money but take a look at no I mean look
at everyone in the photo zoom out again
does anyone in this photo
feel like they have any relation to
anything around them or what's going on
it's a straight and I forgot a hunter at
a kid
I forgot Hunter had a kid I had no idea
he had a child oh it's a cute kid and
who's that that's who's that
is that Hunter's lady
is Hunter doing better can we get these
answers I thought Hunter was just locked
in Malibu smoking Rock but apparently
he's like being a family man in
Nantucket
all of this because he left the laptop
right I I think that's what happened
I think he left a laptop
Hunter Melissa and Beau joined the Biden
so I mean I guess he's doing better what
happened the second chances
it's so
listen
he had a job in an energy company he got
it because of his dad
in a country that you know the president
of it has billions and billions of
dollars exposed in the you know the
Panama papers and everything
who was installed in a CIA coup that we
are now at war with and possibly going
to be nuclear
he's also smoked a lot of crack with
some hookers but people are saying
they're underage I don't know that
they're underage maybe I don't know
but here's my whole thing what about
second chances
it's the holiday do I have to remind you
this season it is you sick [ __ ] do I
have to remind you the season it is
because it is the holiday season it is
the season of Jingle Bells it is the
season of you know it's it's this is the
season of you know it's about family
and I don't want to be
kind of you know emotional here I don't
I try not to get Emo about things
because I usually I'm just trying to be
a goof but I'm really dead serious right
now
this is a time about family
and it's about family whether
it's a crackhead
and his corrupt father
and his dead brother's wife
and a laptop with sensitive government
information it's still about gathering
around the tree
it you know it's still about that it's
still about
hanging the stockings from the fire it's
still about hot cocoa you know is it
about the collapse of a democracy that's
being replaced by a technocracy of
people that have all been blackmailed
yeah hey it but it's the [ __ ]
holidays and we're gonna have a goddamn
we're gonna have a goddamn tree lighting
look he looks great he looks great is
this not a man you would trust
is that not a man I think he's doing
good
and I love that everyone on Twitter by
the way who when you talk about this
you're like you're exposing someone with
an addiction they having a he has an
addiction and how dare you
cool man
cool
um yeah
what do you want me to do not discuss it
it's he's been quite he's the one who
took all the goddamn photos
and the videos but he looks good now
right I mean doesn't he seem he seems to
be turning the page
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 more than 50 million men in
the U.S suffer from male pattern
baldness keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
there are only two FDA approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers them both
they also have convenient virtual
consultation with a licensed medical
provider and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't even have to leave your home
there's 24 7 care and support keeps as a
network of Expert Medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality treatments can start at ten
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions of the two FDA approved
medications to prevent hair loss
treatment plans are affordable typically
have the cost of Pharmacy prices keep
says everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door with
discreet packaging and proven results
remember prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months to see
results to act fast when it comes to
your hair save more spend less if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keps.com Tim Dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keps.com Tim Dillon to
get your first month free
keeps.com Tim Dylan I mean I don't know
I mean this is just this is the big news
it's Twitter gate folks
they're gonna is that a Sig I thought he
had a Sig it's a milkshake
I think that at the end of the day
um this is an American family this is an
American family of a man who quite
possibly sold his soul to the devil to
become president
um and you know you're and now he's
leering through a window
I mean
yeah
he's the president
but
I mean listen on the other side you have
now people that believe that on Hunter
Biden's laptop there are you know videos
of Nancy Pelosi uh cooking children uh
over boiling them in a pot
so that that'll get kicked off again
that'll be they don't the thing about
the Q Anon people which you really have
to kind of be uh impressed by is their
ability to never admit defeat they
really don't like defeat they will stay
with it they'll no matter what the Q
Anon people they will just change they
go yeah well the plan is shifted the
plan has changed and
um you know so I mean this is just it's
it's a story of an American it's the
story of an American family but let's
give them a rest because the economy is
back
let's go to this the economy is doing
well now jobs everybody has a job even
though some of the jobs aren't great
um and you know like that manager at
Walmart shot everybody in the break room
that's a small price to pay you have a
job at least you have a gig
everybody is doing really really well
there is a turnaround in this economy
people are happy even the railroad
people the people that uh that we didn't
want the Republicans means they care
about the people didn't want the
railroad people to be able to use the
bathroom on the job or something that
had no guaranteed sick days the railroad
people I don't know how I feel about
that because I don't I don't certainly I
don't love the ticket takers but I don't
think that's who we're talking about I
don't love the people that punch the
tickets on the railroads uh who they
call they're cold conductions but are
they really conductors they're not
driving the train like I you know on the
Long Island Railroad someone's driving
the train maybe that's the engineer but
these conductors that walk around take
tickets they just they they just punch
your ticket they're kind of like
Carnival people they're kind of I don't
know the difference between them and a
ferris wheel worker so I didn't know
where I was going to land on the uh I
genuine generally go in for the worker I
believe that
um workers should be given rights you
know like uh like voluntary euthanasia
but uh there's something about uh
there's something about this idea the
U.S labor market remains historically
tight with many employers competing for
a limited pool of workers and bidding up
wages despite an uncertain economic
Outlook they added 263
000 jobs in November holding near the
strong gains of the previous three
months so here's the deal the jobless
rate is about 3.7 last month
historically low and it's pushing up
wages let go right now to Craigslist I
want to prove a point go to Craigslist
Los Angeles and see if we can get a job
and I bet you can
so if you're if you're worried about
there go to Craigslist Los Angeles jobs
I want to find a job if you can find a
job in this class you can't complain as
long as you have a job you can't
complain it doesn't matter what the job
is as long as you have one everything is
fine Deli person wanted
deadly person and front counter person
needed both locations close at 5 PM boom
we offer health benefits bonuses
throughout the year full and part-time
please send resume work history
they are the York Bagel and Deli dude
that's not [ __ ] bad what else do we
got this is a good this is good line
cook
for a rotisserie keep going
facial room pedicure manicure station
for rent I need someone to play tennis
with I like this let's do this
I'm looking for someone to play tennis
with on a weekly basis slash coach I
would say I'm beginner intermediate and
would like to play with someone better
than me
this by the way is how you get stabbed
uh answering this ad right here on
Craigslist is how you get put in the
back of a car you do not have to be a
professional tennis coach this is how
you know it's a problem they go I'm
looking for someone to play tennis with
Slash coach and then immediately go you
don't really have to be a coach I just
want to wear your skin
this is a great opportunity for college
student ooh or someone who won't be
missed now there's a great opportunity
for college student or someone out of
school looking for some extra cash
willing to pay 50 an hour for someone to
play tennis with them so these are jobs
that are opening up things are happening
and people feel really good about the
economic Outlook now you know if you can
get a gig uh playing tennis I think you
can probably
dental hygienist look at this energetic
and knowledgeable hygienist
very busy office okay
I love that they said be able to
diagnose gum disease and be a team
player
like be a team player it says
it says we're looking for a hygienist
they can do a superb job of Oral Care be
able to diagnose gum disease and be a
team player like don't just be out for
yourself as a dental hygienist like
don't just be like I'm here to build my
own brand of uh gum disease
identification you got to be a team
player but yeah I mean this is not a big
this I think at the end of the day
um you're going to you go you're going
to see things turn around quicker than
we had even thought and I'm really
excited about that so let's see what
about this Twitter game is anyone
defending themselves what about a video
Gotti agade I cannot pronounce it I'm
not being racist I'm bad with the names
Vidya Visa got a uh I'm not trying to be
I don't I don't know how to do it
um um but is she defending herself uh is
she uh somebody who who uh it's with a J
is is she somebody who uh it feels like
she has to come out and
um say hey I looked at Hunter's [ __ ] and
I decided that it's v i j a y g-a-d-d-e
um
yeah does she come out and say like hey
I looked at the dick I made the decision
that uh it is not uh suitable for people
um I'm wondering if she is lawyering up
right now I imagine she is she's
probably lawyering up and she's probably
um you know getting ready to uh speak
her peace
right Wingers bang for Action because
everybody's you know Caitlyn Jenner by
the way tweeted that this woman should
be indicted did you see uh Caitlyn
Jenner's tweet Caitlyn Jenner tweeted
this find Caitlyn Jenner's tweet uh she
tweeted this
um she tweeted uh I believe it was
something I have it on my phone because
I was I was laughing so hard uh it was
truly a beautiful moment because you
know Caitlyn Jenner is she's no
shrinking violet
um she basically she basically said this
Caitlyn Jenner's tweet here investigate
subpoena indict and criminally charge
Vijaya Gotti for treason
so Caitlyn Jenner is saying this woman
is uh is it's treasonous behavior and
she should be indicted for treason
Caitlyn Jenner America's mother
um weighing in on this and saying that
it must not be tolerated
so Elon Musk is now taking over Donald
Trump's uh job of of like the country is
going to
you know it seemed like for aim two
Indian Americans at Center of Joe
Biden's son's laptop story it's
hilarious I mean
foreign
goes hey what's going on here this seems
like it's a First Amendment issue two
Indian Americans congressman rocana and
Vijaya Gotti prominently figuring U.S
President Joe Biden's son Hunter's
laptop story
um
yeah so the story claim would contain
emails retrieved from a laptop belonging
to Hunter the New York Post said it
learned that the emails existed from
Trump Trump's ex-white house chief
strategist Steve Bannon and obtained the
emails from Trump's personal lawyer at
the time Rudy Giuliani Twitter initially
limited the distribution of the story
citing concerns and it could be the
result of a foreign disinformation
campaign that hack and league but the
social media company quickly backtracked
on its response with then CEO Jack
Dorsey calling the decision to block the
link unacceptable rokana is the
Democratic Congressman
representing Silicon Valley in the U.S
House of Representatives while Vijaya
Gotti an attorney got a served as
general counsel as the head of legal
policy
um a series of tweets along with the
internal Communications of Twitter was
released when writer Matt Okay blah blah
blah
um yeah musk said in a tweet rokana is
great because rokana was the one pushing
for the release of this stuff going like
why is this being blocked why can this
they even suspended Trump's
Communications uh secretary director uh
who asked about this stuff or who shared
it
um rocana was like what is going on so
we don't know right this is what fuels
the conspiracy theories because people
go what is on the laptop
but I think a lot of it is that they
just didn't want Trump to win
and these people again they they do
believe like these people that I've
spoken to in that part of Northern
California it's they don't get as much
sun up there uh it's very pretty but it
you know they are you know they're
Eggheads right they're they're people
that truly believe they have lived
online they've grown up online they're
formative relationships have all been
online they've met their significant
others online
um everything to them uh it has a a a
justification in their own mind and I
think the justification here uh was that
if this story caught fire it could
prevent Joe Biden from winning the
presidency I think they said this hurts
Biden's chances uh if it comes out and
it helps Biden if it doesn't come out
that seems to be because even though you
could say it's not political you could
say it's about the hack and leak and it
might be I'm sure that was a concern I'm
sure they did think because everyone's
paranoid right now about the hack and
leak because everybody's like Rush is
everywhere like Russia's in the [ __ ]
everywhere they're coming they're
hacking they're leaking
um they were like Wikileaks Julian
assandro like that's all Russia it's at
the behest of Russia it's all foreign
intelligence campaign
um so he's Bradley Manning Russia that's
Now Chelsea Manning uh he was at Russia
uh Snowden well Snowden is in Russia now
um but you have all of these leakers
that have leaked Barrett Brown these
people that have leaked government
information sensitive information uh
that's damaged The credibility of our
government in the eyes of its citizens
and you know other countries and sure
other countries have a vested interest
in that stuff getting out
um so I'm sure there was some type of
rationale uh over there at Twitter
but I think it's a lot of smarmy kind of
student council president energy it's
Mom energy it's you better you don't
even know what you're wanting to see
energy it's it's TR it's the parent you
know your parents will put something
over your eyes sometimes in New York
City early on in the 90s when they were
like you know porn ads or ads for you
know XXX clubs strip clubs my mother
would put her hands over my eyes uh so I
wouldn't see the women now I'm gay you
see what happened mom uh but what
happens is that's what it is is you you
just have Vijaya a gotti it sounds like
Sanjaya and vagina it's the two names
that's what I'm struggling with it
because I don't want to do the wrong
thing but it sounds like Sanjaya and
vagina it's vagina whatever she seemed
I'm listen I'm sure these people aren't
demons from hell but
you know they are the types of people
who they don't want you to make your own
choice so you do have uh and I'm sure
listen content moderation is difficult
you don't you know Kanye tweeted a
swastika
and intermingled with the Star of David
and Elon Musk had to get rid of him
Kanye had gone on Alex Jones he said he
loves Hitler
and that everybody brings good things to
the table especially Hitler
um
and Alex Jones was struggling with that
because you know Alex has many things
but he's not really he's not a lover of
Hitler
so it was very interesting to see Alex
in that position of having to go like
Alex was uncomfortable and you got to
give it to Kanye Kanye went on Infowars
and made Alex uncomfortable that in and
of itself you know is an accomplishment
of course it it also does come up with
the correlation that he is like a Nazi
um but he's it's it's it's fascinating
it's interesting that he became a Nazi
it's it's not right that he became a
Nazi but this is you know as a talking
point at dinner when you're sitting
there with people it comes up you're
like yeah Kamya he's like a Nazi now
people like I no
it's something that's uh so Joe Biden
had to tweet this he goes I just want to
make a few things clear the Holocaust
happened Hitler was a demonic figure and
instead of giving it a platform our
political leader should be calling out
rejecting aunties so this is the problem
on the right side so on the left we have
many problems but on the right your boss
sizing again that's what you do that's
why we don't really like the show
because you just say that one side's bad
and the other side's bad and you just
don't want to here's the problem with
the right now is with the Kanye stuff
there's always a like uh a bot with them
like there's like a there's always like
an asterect with his stuff they're like
yeah he's wrong
but like no one's just going out and
going like hey this is not good people
are going like well you know he's
talking
and sometimes we need to have
conversations
and sometimes we need to speak akany is
like I love Hitler and people like
that's a conversation that we should
have right now it's an important
conversation to have it's a good it's
just as important as how to get clean
water and give workers rights and and
try to like you know give people Freedom
it's important to talk about why this
narcissist loves Hitler
it's important it's a narcissistic
rapper Who's a billionaire who loves
Hitler and that's what we should spend
our time in America discussing because
there's there's too many people on the
right
that are pretty comfortable with a lot
of what he's saying there's not it's not
everybody and it's probably not even a
majority let's hope but it is there's a
small group of people on the right
that are you know kind of let's say uh
receptive to some of the language that
he's using like very receptive so those
are the people that are like listen
listen
I don't agree with what he's saying
but
I think this is a worthwhile
conversation about Hitler let's talk
about Hitler
let's talk about people who love Hitler
why do they love Hitler it's a
worthwhile discussion to have and I
don't know I just don't know I don't
know if it's a worthwhile just cut to be
honest I don't know if it's a I don't
know if a narcissist uh who's maybe in
the throes of a mental break comes out
and goes I love Hitler he's not making a
point about uh Israel you know like he's
not making like a political Point here
he's saying he likes Hitler
so
there's just it's just I think
unfortunately there's a lot of people
that are uh a little too comfortable
with that
and and you're singing but then I think
the Hitler things seem to push some of
those people because that that's where
it was going and a lot of people knew
that's where it was going and some
people were like he's just frustrated
and he's just he's just he's just blown
off steam he's frustrated he's blown off
steam it's like you know he's just
saying things that no one can say
because against culture is saying it's
not a big gem then he goes on and goes
well I love Hitler and then even those
people started to go yeah maybe uh give
them a timeout
maybe shut them down maybe shut him down
a little bit but they had to remove him
from because that's the thing with
Twitter it's like we're all for free
speech but at a certain point what if
what if Twitter in six months is just
swastikas like the whole the whole feed
it's just your whole feed is people
tweeting different kind of swastikas
like some are really cool looking and
you're like well this certainly went a
different direction but it is you know
it's interesting people gotta tweet you
know symbols
and I'm a free speech guy I believe
people should say what they want to say
but you should also be a an adult and
you should be intelligent enough to
realize what Chobani yogurt might not
want to advertise under a swastika
this holiday season if you're looking
for a unique gift that inspires
curiosity travel and culture give the
gift of Babel Babel is a language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you'll finally be able
to discuss the wonder that comes with
learning a new language this is
something I've always talked about I've
always been embarrassed that I didn't I
don't know another language you know
everyone from other countries they all
know English they all know multiple
languages and we you know we we're not
taught that you know
um with Babel you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
that's crazy other language learning
apps use AI for their lesson plans but
Baba lessons were created by over 150
language experts voiced by real native
speakers not computers right now get up
to 55 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com Tim here's the other thing
if you go away and you can learn a
little bit of the language it's very
impressive to the people that you've
gone away with girlfriend boyfriend
whatever also if you don't have those
things and you just want to talk to
people in that country it's super like
you know impressive and people can talk
to you it's you know so there's no
negative here right now get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com Tim that's babble.com Jim for
up to 55 off your subscription Babble
language for life
they're just trying to sell Chobani
flips
now I'm not saying that you should
[ __ ] you know not let people speak
but when you're gonna tweet a swastika
and some of your platform is AD Revenue
you have to understand that there's
people you know at Nest Cafe that are
just trying to sell [ __ ] instant
[ __ ] coffee that don't necessarily
want
um you know to advertise on uh the
platform
so that's really what happens and uh you
know maybe the subscription service will
work you know
I don't know I don't know if that's
gonna work but maybe it will
because I think a lot of the ad people
are just going to get out of there
people like well the advertisers don't
care about free they've never cared
about Free Speech idiots you think
McDonald's cared what you had to say
about the Iraq war no they never cared
they're companies that are trying to
make a bottom line often poisoning you
they don't care about your ability to
speak freely that's not what they've
ever cared about they didn't care about
it when people were saying we shouldn't
torture people at Guantanamo we
shouldn't invade Iraq we should invade
Afghanistan we shouldn't pass a patriot
act none of these [ __ ] advertisers
gave a [ __ ] did was Chili's standing
with you when you refused when you when
you said the Iraq War was [ __ ] was
Chili's like I want my freedom to say
that America shouldn't do this my baby
back baby back baby but no they're
trying to sell you [ __ ] potato salad
they don't care this idea this new idea
that like well corporations are against
the people some of them all are I don't
care that whole thing about like Disney
they were like d you know Disney and
because they got in some fight down
there about Disney because apparently
Disney's chopping your kids dicks off in
the theme park or whatever Disney's
doing there was a gay movie that
supposedly bombed get this up there's a
movie called strange world
which by the way
like how bad like everyone accuses the
people of Hollywood of sneaking gay
themes in it's this is how bad it is if
they were doing that you think they'd be
better at it than calling the movie
strange world like that's the movie and
I don't even know how gay it is it's
probably like one gay character what
happens with these people is they flip
out because there's like one
hippopotamus who like may be gay it's
not like two sloths are sucking each
other off for the whole movie it's like
there's one like like very mild
suggestion that a character might be gay
unless I'm wrong unless it has jumped
the shark
um
strange world is predicted to go down as
one of Disney's biggest ever Financial
failures with its losses projected to be
in 100 million plus range right wing
culture wars Spectators are hooting with
Pleasures what they see is evidence of
diversity and inclusion efforts ruining
Hollywood specifically blaming director
Don Hall and his co-director and
screenwriter Qui Ninja's choice to make
Ethan gay so who is Ethan
in the movie
um
with uh strange world is about I'll get
the storyline here Walt Disney Animation
Studios tells the story of three
generations of clad man clade men
starting with Brash Adventurer Jaeger
clay Dennis Quaid who drags his son
Searcher Jake Gyllenhaal along with uh
his ex Along on his Expeditions Jaegers
celebrated hero decided to a lifelong
quest to be the first to pass over the
mountain range that has kept their
Homeland
um avalonia isolated from the rest of
the world Searcher is more concerned
with the natural wonders in their
backyard including an electricity
generating plant they encounter where is
the gay guy
flashing forward 25 years we see that
Searchers cultivated the plants
incandescent grape-like fruit into an
energy resource called Panda how many
drugs are people on to write this
transferring avalonia from a horse and
buggy Backwater into a Utopia flying
cars and technological innovation he's
also Father to a teenage son Ethan
who's shockingly enough does not want to
follow in Searchers footsteps this worry
Searcher especially
um since Ethan shows signs of having
more common with Jager
um
I'm in pursuing Ethan searcher's wife
Meridian also gets dragged along which
is a good I I don't understand here how
gay could this possibly get like unless
they're you know like how gay could this
possibly be first of all calling in a
strange world is already going to make
these people paranoid this is not this
is not like you might as well call the
movie like hey kids you want to try
something different
everything that these people do
[Music]
um
is not is not smart you don't call it
strange well I just don't understand the
inclusion of a gay character it's like
such a minimal aspect of the plot it's
seemingly it doesn't seem to center
around this dude's sexuality but again
there's people that don't want their
kids to see anything with a gay
character in it which is fine it's
absolutely fun but I don't think this is
like over the line like if it was like
if it was like it's a strange world it's
about three generations of men two of
the generations are now women and it
shows how in order to save your Homeland
you have to transition into another form
so that you can slip through the portal
like if it was really blatant I would go
okay I understand uh how people are
getting a little upset here but one gay
character
there's been a ton of characters that
are kind of gay in all of these Disney
movies ah
like if I understand if they were doing
that like if the Disney movie if the one
cartoon was just jerking the other
cartoon and said like are you close and
the other cartoons like yes I'm close
and then the other cartoons like do you
want to taste it and they're like yes
and then they came all over the face and
that Disney thing of like that Pixar
comes everywhere and then one of the you
know I get it then I'd be like yeah it's
weird but
I don't know it seems a bit uh paranoid
with this one
thing wouldn't be I think Kanye should
cut his next job should be voicing the
character of something like just sneak
him back in sneak him back into the
animation
the anime world but I did see that bomb
Strange World and I'm like well yeah the
[ __ ] title the title's the worst
[ __ ] title that you could give a
movie with a gay character I mean it's
crazy like where are you where we're
just going to take the kids to see
strange world
it's a strange world where girls are
boys and boys are girls and everybody
touches everybody's private parts it's
called strange world
everybody's black and gay in this new
movie called strange world
call it America and they'll go see it
it's just odd to me also can we be
honest about all of the new Disney
characters with whatever race they're
just ugly
like all of the new animated characters
are gross whatever race they are it's
not about that it's just the faces are
disgusting like really really ugly and I
don't know why that is but the animators
have these clumpy clay-like goop-like
faces
are just gross
they all have like big noses right Kanye
kidding but no but they all they're all
gross now I wouldn't want my kids to see
this because everyone's ugly
one day they're gonna make a Disney
movie about Twitter gate
it's gonna be animated and it's gonna be
like Aladdin
and it's gonna have the jayagate and
rokana two Indian American leads great
great great one for Freedom one not so
much and it'll all be about Hunter God
of Biden's cockpick
and they'll be singing songs and it'll
be like a fun Pixar animated thing about
Twitter but listen listen I hope
the Biden family has a great Christmas I
hope this doesn't go I hope this Scandal
doesn't get in the way of what I imagine
will be a good Christmas for them you
know I'm such a believer in the holidays
I'm a Believer in family I'm a Believer
in getting over the things in life that
present you from being happy whether
it's a crack addiction or it's a hack
and leak campaign whatever whatever your
personal problems are you gotta get uh
rid of them that's really the deal uh we
talked on the patreon about Casey
Anthony on the Rothschild episode and on
the regular episode I'm a Stan of Casey
Anthony I haven't watched the doc I'm
going to tonight I've always been a Stan
um of Casey Anthony
um I hope to God this opens up other
opportunities for her because I think
when people see her on this documentary
you know this is not easy to get cast
and things but I'm hoping the casting
directors now look at her uh as someone
that they could potentially bring in to
do some roles I've always felt that she
had more talent in her than what uh
people were you know she was being
underutilized I've kind of believed that
Always Forever about Casey
um I just hope that this opens doors for
her I hope this gets her opportunity and
I'm glad that peacock did it I'm glad
that peacock is is using three parts
three hours or whatever it is to do a
documentary uh on an innocent woman who
and I'm dead serious I'm a Stan there's
there's certain people like I like when
it comes to yay I'll be like [ __ ]
anti-semitic when it comes to Trump I'll
be like he's a liar when it comes to
Biden would be like he does not know
where he is he would lie if he knew how
to do it anymore but when it comes to
Casey Anthony there's three words
innocent star now
that's what I want I want Casey Anthony
to [ __ ] shoot Pat I mean how great
would it be in a few years if there's a
new movie coming out with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Casey Anthony
let that would show me that cancel
culture is over and then America like
you could bounce back you could come
back Kanye could come back he can he's
just got to say I'm sorry he said I love
Hitler
none of the hunter Biden's back it's not
a big deal he smoked crack with some
horror and then killed her and brought
his lava or something it doesn't matter
there's nothing that you can't get over
with family
if you have your family with you
is there anything more important to
Casey Anthony's and family
I don't think so
and in this time of the holidays is
Thanksgiving happening or that
thanksgiving's done
Christmas is now coming
and then the new year and it's about
family
and that's why I say Kanye yay loves his
family
Casey Anthony loves her family Trump
loves his family these are the types of
people we need to be teaching our kids
about not this gay Disney star
Donald Trump Casey Anthony and Kanye
West
those are great Americans that we can be
proud of we can show our kids if you
work hard if you believe in yourself
you can be like these people Hunter
Biden Casey Anthony
Donald Trump
yay
I'm I'm all for it I'm all for it no
seriously I'm all for it I know that
people are gonna get mad at me or come
at me and be like yeah well you know
like Casey Anthony was accused of
killing a kid
shut up
how much how much time does this woman
have to do how much negative [ __ ]
literally does she have to go through
for putting a child in a bag
I don't want to live in a society where
people that put their child in a bag
cannot be Stars
I don't I don't want to live in a
society where it's just some because
someone said they love Hitler
people now think they're a bad guy
I don't want to live in that Society
I don't want to live in a society where
putting your child in a bag in the woods
or liking Hitler
or smoking a lot of crack with [ __ ]
and then taking photos of it means
you've done something wrong
I don't want to live in that Society
if you want to live in that Draconian
Society
that puritanical insane Society where
every mistake is analyzed all the time
over and over
just because someone likes Hitler or
killed their child
I say let him back in take a couple of
year time out and then let them back in
let's see what she's got let's get Casey
Anthony the new show Wednesday on
Netflix which is [ __ ] pretty good
um I watched an episode of it my my uh
my godson's mother likes it
um
and uh we watched an episode my godson
doesn't really like it he just likes to
watch me play a president Z for him he
loves it because he said Chinese and he
knows that we're done here
um and no country deserves to be done as
much as we do let's be quite High when
they come in here will anyone go how did
this happen
um truly I mean if China ends up winning
which we don't want them to but let's
say they do and they will will anyone
seriously look at each other and go how
did this even happen
how did this where do you think this
went wrong
I just I don't get it it was going so
well wasn't it
um but if Wednesday if they're you know
Christina Ricci does a little cameo in
the Wednesday show because she played
Wednesday in the original Adams Family
movie what if
here's an idea
that Cameo goes to Casey Anthony
why not would she what if she killed it
what if she killed it
what if Casey Anthony kills that role
kills it dead in a bag in the forest
dead
what's the big deal
I don't know
we'll see you next week go and get a
tree don't let the pagans win get a tree
put up the ornaments
and watch in for Wars and watch Kanye
say loves Hitler and get your family
together and drink some cocoa and watch
the Casey Anthony documentary it's a
beautiful time of year and we're all at
a beautiful place
thank you so much we'll see you soon
we're on patreon real Child episodes out
where we go in depth uh as to why Casey
Anthony is innocent
um and uh we will see you next week I'll
be on the road spotlight casino in uh I
don't know some dump it but no it's you
know it's lovely in California somewhere
India who knows uh Irvine Improv if you
want to come it's New Year's Eve I might
get BOTOX live on stage Irvine Improv
New Year's Eve spotlight casino
um website timberlandcomedy.com tickets
are all live there for things thank you
guys so much support our sponsors uh
they help Casey Anthony live thank you